Speaker 1: OK, a lot of people,
you know, sometimes I think, like,
OK, people get banned on Twitter, people get
banned on YouTube and stuff like that. But like
even now during calls, people are getting banned
on our discord and there's a bunch more that are
about to get banned. It's crazy what people are
able to do. Let's go next to S. D. from Dallas,
Texas, you're on the air.
Speaker 4:
Hello, David, how are you? I am doing well. What a
pleasure is all mine and expect this one to sleep
so well. So on yesterday's show, you covered these
massive protests like these unprecedented protests
going on in Cuba. And I know they're multifaceted,
like there may not be a single thing everyone's
pointing to that everyone puts the blame.
But a lot of our Cuban-American friends, and
especially the greater Miami area, have raised
the call for intervention of some sorts. What,
if any, kind of intervention would you support?
Speaker 1: So we talked to one of the people is
actually the mayor of Miami who did that, whose
father was also the first Cuban American mayor of
Miami there. Talk about military intervention. So
I'm completely opposed to military intervention. I
think basically what needs to happen in Cuba
is, oh, you got what? You got a dog there.
Speaker 4: No, I'm walking
Speaker 1: kind of like a dog barks Sorry,
we my preference would be as
someone so so just for context,
I'm an anti authoritarian progressive, so
of course, I'm against the Cuban regime.
Fidel Castro coming to power in nineteen
fifty nine, remaining in power until 2008,
then handing power to his brother. Right. There's
nothing progressive about that. As a progressive,
I have to be against that. I'm also
against the American embargo of Cuba.
And I think that that primarily really hurts the
Cuban people. It's not gotten Cuba to change their
system of government, which supposedly was was
what it was intended to pressure them to do.
So what I would like to see in terms of Cuba is
I would like to do away with the American embargo
and to then work in a global coalition
to encourage Cuba to hold elections
and to not be authoritarian. But and this is a
big but it can't be that the U.S. is in any way
involved in the election or runs a candidate
or any of that stuff that so we have to
be able to draw clear lines. I am not for
American intervention in a Cuban election,
but what I would love to see is for us to get off
of the hypocrisy of the Cuban embargo, start to
send aid and do more things to help the Cuban
people and work with a diverse I mean, listen,
even, you know, we're hearing from world leaders
about it's time for Cuba to actually have real
elections and that that would be my preference.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I kind of see what you're going
with there. I am in terms of lifting the embargo,
I'm absolutely on board with returning free
enterprise to the island. Yep. But I think
we have to be a little cautious because we
see this with a lot of countries that were once
authoritarian, is that authoritarian development
is now a new trend on their rise. So I don't know
if only promoting free enterprise is necessarily
going to turn the island into a liberal democracy.
Speaker 1: Oh, I totally agree with you. No,
it won't. And in fact, it's important to
understand a lot of the new authoritarianism,
including these parties in Europe, for
example. It's what's going on in Cuba. Again,
it's been since fifty nine. It's a totally
different animal. What's going on there? And the
approach needs to be different. I agree with you.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah, yeah, and for record,
like there are like there has been a regime in
exile here in the United States, I shouldn't say
regime like the Cuban government in exile here
in the United States, that sort of like a lot of
people looking to free Cuba look up to. So I was
Speaker 1: possibly comment on that.
I don't know if they're right wing authoritarians
or I don't I don't know any I couldn't
possibly comment on that. I have no
knowledge of what their perspective is.
Speaker 4: OK, David, I'll leave you
there. Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. My pleasure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I want to be if I don't know
about something, I just can't comment. You know, a
government in exile, that could be anything. They
could be whatever. OK, let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phone lines momentarily.